shelby's in tampa florida
hi shelby how are you hi dave thanks for
taking my call i'm
great thank you good how can i help
my question is this i want to know
what i should be doing with my income
we've gotten to a point that all of our
debt is paid off and we have a couple
hundred left
after we do our every dollar budget out
of my husband's income
i work sales i actually sell real estate
um
i'm wondering i know you say 15 but i'm
45 and i personally only have about 22
000 saved towards my retirement so i
need to kick it up i don't want to work
till i'm
100 and my husband would love to retire
sooner
so how much he's already putting inside
the 15 but how much should i take from
my check
to put into retirement and also pay off
our mortgage
those are the two things i want to do
with my money what do you think is a
realistic split i think it should quit
being your money
i know but no i know but no i don't know
but
yeah i think it should quit being your
money
and i think he should have quit having
his money and his retirement
we have a retirement plan we have money
and we are going to combine them and of
our household income
we are going to save 15 until our home
is paid off and when it is paid off
we're going to save even more
and we are going to be retire able to
retire with dignity
his 401k should have your name on it as
the beneficiary
your ira should have his name on it
as the beneficiary
it does i just get nervous because real
estate is not always consistent it has
been for the past couple years but
because it's not consistent
i almost look at it as bonus money so i
like attempted to like put half into
you know half of my checks into my
retirement and half of it towards the
mortgage and just like knock it out
you know that's that's what i'm tempted
to do and i don't know if that's the
right thing
it's not but you're saying you're saying
mortgage first no
i'm saying the right thing is that the
two of you combine all of your finances
so we've got his 200 dollar surplus plus
anything you make it sounds like his
gravy as well
we're going to apply all of that we're
looking at our total household income
we're putting 15 percent of what we
estimate
our total household income it's an
estimate because we don't know exactly
what you're going to make
but we know what you made last year and
we know what you're trekking for this
year
and you can't predict real estate
exactly i know that but you're not going
to be off
100 you're not going to be off 50
you're going to know fairly close to
what you're going to make what'd you
make last year
about 100 okay what's the chances of you
making 40 this year
none unless you sit on your butt
right right right okay so the chances
are pretty good you're going to be
100-ish
is that fair uh-huh yeah might make a
little more might make a little less
might make a lot more and that'd be
awesome we'll deal with that problem if
we run into it
so what's he make
um his gross is about 80 but his net
is about 4 200. we're dealing with gross
for the 15
so let's say you made 120 he made 80.
let's call that 200. and let's just say
that's our estimate for 2021
and that's an easy 30 000. that's 2500 a
month needs to be going into retirement
that's 15 stick to the fifteen percent
total okay
then above that let's get the house paid
off because
yeah with you it has the exact same
effect of what your emotions are telling
you you wanna do
we're putting money in investments and
we're paying off the house both of those
things lead to security
true both of those things lead to you
catching up or you feel like you're
behind
and you know what else it does for you
shelby
again i hope i'm not projected into i am
i'm directly projecting you called us
it's going to keep you from feeling like
the little helper around your house
you're an integral part of that home
you're not just the little helper
and you've got this this idea that
your husband's the breadwinner he's off
trucking and just whatever
this is fun money hobby money yeah
whatever nickel and dimes you come up
with will help you feel a little more
secure
and you actually make more than he does
you make way more than he does
you're a chief contributor in this house
in probably a hundred different ways
but when you have his money and your
money you also have
his house in your house and his roles
and your roles and it keeps you from
having a united front in this home
and it might even like you said dave you
put all that money in a pot it may be
that
200 of dollars that technically is
what's left over
goes to his home depot fund or goes to
his puzzle building i don't know what
weird things he does
and then your money goes to x y and z
the same dollar amount it's not your
money anymore
but you've got to get off this we're
just i'm just out playing around
frivolously and look we had a good year
or two
y'all are on the same team same house
same psychology same
emotion same spirit and same financial
journey here yeah
yeah and they're just different it's um
and sometimes when you
can't predict your income because it's
straight commissioner self-employed
it feels less valid yeah i mean
like my grandmother my grandpa worked
for alcohol aluminum for 38 years
and even when i was making seven figures
doing this little radio thing i do
she would bless her heart in her you
know in her she kept asking me when i
was gonna get a real job that's right
that's
right
because because i wasn't on anybody's
payroll
you know and it's just there's something
that's invalid about that income if it's
not
if it's not quote steady or predictable
that's right and it is
it's it's actually more valid uh because
more tied to actual
value being added every day but the uh
so
yeah that's part of it here's the thing
um
it's a very practical thing you make
different decisions you make better
decisions
and you're more unified when you stop
using
the wrong pronouns and you start saying
we ours us
our household income is this and
i contribute this amount he contributes
that amount to our household income
our goals are this i want to feel good
at retirement
from the combination of our retirement
plans
should something happen to him i want to
feel like
i'm going to be okay in that and that's
a valid goal of valid
value to have in the process
uh but the other thing that ends up
happening is it enhances your
relationship
dramatically you folks i get these calls
every day just about on the show
and i always talk about you know change
your pronouns to we you're french now
wee-wee
and so but john over the years i i'll
never forget the first time it happened
i can even show you exactly where i'm
standing in a hallway outside of a
meeting room
we were teaching financial peace
university with an overhead projector
and this affluent couple was in
financial peace university which in the
early days
hardly any affluent people came they
were all just completely stone cold
probes
nowadays everybody goes to it because we
can all know we can do better
and they come out after the class was
over they said you've completely changed
our marriage
and i went dude the sex class is down
the hall i didn't
how did i change your marriage and they
started by making us work together we
combined our goals we combined our fears
we combined our dreams and we've been in
marriage counseling
with five different counselors over 18
years and that weren't able to do this
and we were able to do it because of
stupid budget
i love it because you gave them a tool
you didn't say just talk about it and
feel it and talk about it feel it you
gave them
small content to combine your vision
and then you gotta go do it that's what
a budget does it's an action step